and two the direct acknowledgement that
you have hurt people around you and i
mean you know there's not really that
it's
like i've alarmed and i've upset people
with my behavior
it to me reads yeah it's a very sort of
insular statement it's more about me
than it is about anybody else out there
and yeah i'm sorry if i upset or alarmed
you if i caused you some kind of
emotional distress in reacting to me but
not i'm sorry for the people i hurt or
endangered or whatever else
what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today john how
are you i am very anticipated what we're
about to talk about so we were out and
about this news dropped as we were on
our way back and i was like well
well
we have some thoughts
already we gotta talk about it you knew
we would ezra miller this sounds like a
publicist statement in all honesty
probably is ezra miller has issued a
statement to variety here's how it goes
having recently gone through a time of
crisis on infinite earth
through a time of intense crisis
i now understand that i am suffering
complex mental health issues and have
begun ongoing treatment i want to
apologize to everyone that i have
alarmed and upset with my past behavior
you know when you like read it like i
heard it on the road and then you read
it it just
i am committed to doing the necessary
work to get back to a healthy safe and
productive stage
in my life
i'm very apprehensive towards the
statement because yeah i mean i think
all of us would more than likely agree
most of us even the ones who would say
uh you know who are the ones who are for
ezra miller i think there's no denying
that there is a mental health issues
that definitely need to be worked on
that definitely need to be treated that
there has to be something for it so at
least they're owning up to that right
it's just there's some specifically
calculated words because it's still not
about owning up to the past actions just
saying that when you take the time
especially to issue a statement one
working with the publicist you one would
assume that if they really did feel
responsible for their actions or that
they did do something wrong
they would might
actually be a little bit more
forthcoming with saying that i know that
sounds presumptuous so i'm sure there's
more to actually come out the reason why
i'm going with there with that mentality
is because of the fact that
just because someone has mental health
issues doesn't mean there shouldn't be
consequences for one's actions like yes
they should go get mental health
treatment sure at the same time
punishment should be dealt in some
fashion everything with dakota iron
irons that we learned of what started at
the age of 12 i think that in itself is
a terrible thing that the amount of
reports of like terrorizing hawaii
whether
a fraction of them were were not true or
were who knows bottom line is like you
know that some of this is true to say
the least there are enough events at
least some of them have to be authentic
and i think that it doesn't matter if
you you have just mental health issues
or not like there should be consequences
for that because bottom line is this
individual is more likely to get off the
hook due to the fact of their power and
fame and they should not be able to get
off the hook due to their power and fame
while one can read this and interpret it
like oh they must be owning up they're
technically not owning up to
the things they have actually done i'm
really not trying to be mr dramatic
about it i'm really not because if they
did i'd be like oh well at least i owned
up i still think there's got to be
consequences this seems very calculated
in the specific word choices it does it
does it's one of those things where you
know my initial reaction is i want to
believe this is true i wanna put the
best you know faith in people and i
don't know because yeah this is very
well packaged it's very sort of
conscientious in how it is worded you i
don't wanna be so cynical but this says
in the article that a representative of
the actor sent this statement in so i
gotta imagine this may have been
workshopped with a few people it's hard
because i can understand why somebody
would be inclined to accept this but
there also yeah isn't a naming of the
specific past behaviors that they want
to own up to or what specific kind of
treatment is and hey they don't have to
give they don't owe us all of their
intimate medical details of course and
it's good that they're seeking treatment
and all that other stuff but yeah i mean
it does
read as a bit of a gloss just to be like
hey sorry to anybody alarmed with my
past behavior moving right on past that
i feel like yeah this is probably a bid
in a lot of ways to maintain as little
disruption of ezra miller's status at
the moment as possible and i think what
you said is absolutely true i wish this
came with maybe a pledge to
take some time away from the public eye
or to take some time away from
everything to really go and do the work
acknowledge what the work is not only on
the personal side getting treatment
that's great yes but also you know how
are you going to kind of at least
address and or atone for these strange
occurrences that you've been putting
people through across the country so
yeah it reads is a bit clean while i
really hope the work is getting done
there's not really a specific
acknowledgement of that stuff here so i
i don't know i don't know how much i'll
wait and see ezra miller shouldn't be at
the same status they are right now while
they're taking care of this issue i feel
like they should take all that time to
do the personal and external work and
then maybe
come back into the to the acting world
or whatever not that this is really
necessarily commenting on their career
in particular but you know that's why
the statement is here you know at least
they're aware of some of the damages
that have actually been happening and it
sounds like the pressure's been cooking
like it's really interesting that you
know that whole felony burglary charge
comes out i did see on social media that
there were people going that there was
some other neighbor if i'm not mistaken
please feel free to add on in the
comments if i am incorrectly uh
remembering this but i believe there
were some other neighborhoods like this
would just go over there all the time
they would borrow from each other this
whole story is getting blown out of
proportion and that's not exactly how it
is
maybe if it's the same time there's
still a felony burglary charge
it seems like there's always some
defense you shouldn't have to break
done for all that's like all the more
reason you should have to break in then
if you have that well of a rapport with
somebody then it would stand a reason
they would just allow you to access it
and then while there was like that
charge and then of course warner
brothers with the the reported uh three
options they have for ezra miller like
this looks like it's going down option
numero uno right here of what they would
want ezra to do it's very easy to be
calculated and manipulative with your
wording though situations like this i'm
like this is like a a thing that has to
really be out there not just with your
words like clarity specificity with your
words but also actions that follow
forward you know and time yeah
you know
and two the direct acknowledgement that
you have hurt people around you and i
mean you know but there's not really
that it's
like i've alarmed and i've upset people
with my behavior
it to me reads yeah it's a very sort of
insular statement it's more about me
than it is about anybody else out there
and yeah i'm sorry if i upset or alarmed
you if i caused you some kind of
emotional distress in reacting to me but
not i'm sorry for the people i hurt or
endangered or whatever else yeah so
that's pretty much where we're coming
from on the matter i hope that the
people who
are legitimately harmed post-actions can
find some type of resolve and resolution
hope that the treatment goes well for
ezra miller for the future
and
we're one step closer to seeing the
flash
one step closer damage control
damage control
get this [ __ ] under control yeah no i
wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised if
somebody made a few calls and threatened
no you know
like the fact that ezra's finally
speaking it doesn't seem coincidental at
all it's like oh this is all really
lining up with everything we've been
hearing reported on yeah and a weird
time to drop the information yeah like
evening and los angeles yeah weird
timing yeah all right guys well what do
you think about this uh leave your
thoughts down below my hair has been in
my eyes this whole time apologies see
you soon
[Music]
you